[Music]
when you have become adjusted to simple
living in regard to your bodily wants do
not preen yourself about the
accomplishment and so likewise if you
are a water drinker do not on every
occasion say that you are a water
drinker and if you ever want to train to
develop physical endurance do it by
yourself and not for outsiders to behold
do not throw your arms around statues
but on occasion when you are very
thirsty take cold water into your mouth
and then spit it out without telling
anybody
chapter 47 has to do with our bodies and
also even more so with our minds in
particular our faculty of choice and our
judgments about ourselves
but it has even more to do with the
outside world comprised of other people
what we can call the social world which
for us also includes the online internet
world just as much as the the world that
we socialize in face to face
and epictetus is counseling us against
something that we could call outward
show or vanity or even if you like pride
in what we have disciplined our body to
do so this is you know if we want to use
another metaphor here this is a way of
saying
how people depart from the stoic path if
you think about
the stoic path as being this
almost like going up a mountain right
and and going around a bunch of twists
and turns but eventually getting to a
place
where what you're supposed to be
enjoying
is
freedom and tranquility and happiness
there's a lot of steps along the road
and a person might go part of the way
along the road and then veer off into
something quite different and
disciplining the body works like that as
well if your main goal is to
discipline your body so that you can
actually not be bothered by it and and
not have its demands
pressing upon you not see it as
something that you have to attend to all
the time so that you then can make
progress as a stoic that's one thing if
you're disciplining the body because you
want to subdue it or you want to show
everybody how tough you are or
you know make yourself
feel like like you're really in charge
of things this is one reason why a lot
of people do in fact engage in bodily
discipline because it gives them the
feeling of control
over something that the stoics would say
actually is outside of your control
then you've departed from the stoic path
in very serious ways and so we'll look
at some of the examples that he gives
here and the advice and then i've got a
few other examples to throw in as well
so he says when you've adjusted to
simple living in regard to your bodily
wants
do not preen yourself about the
accomplishment so for example if you are
a water drinker what does that mean if
you're a water drinker instead of
somebody who's drinking wine or drinking
other things right if that's your your
thing then don't go around telling
everybody do not on every occasion say
that you are a water drinker if it
happens to come up and somebody really
presses you on it that's fine for you to
tell them but you don't need to like go
to the bar and say i only drink water
you know you don't need to make a big
thing of it as we say
if you want to train to develop physical
endurance do it by yourself and not for
outsiders to behold as he says here's a
great funny example do not throw your
arms around statues but on occasion when
you're very thirsty take cold water into
your mouth and then spit it out without
telling anybody so we've got a real
contrast here now what's this business
about throwing your arms around statues
well this is something that um the great
cynic philosopher diogenes was supposed
to have done in order to uh he would do
this when it was cold to accustom his
body to the cold right he wanted to
subdue his body so that he could he
could show that the mind was more
important than the body or the soul or
the will or whatever you want to say
so
how do we do these sorts of things today
here we we have just a multitude of
examples and i think that we are in
a culture
that has many more temptations towards
this sort of behavior
than say 50 years ago or a hundred years
ago it's not that people didn't exercise
or diet or do anything like that but um
we have turned it into you know
lifestyle choices and and we've we've
got an entire
industry while whole industries that
cater to this sort of thing as a matter
of fact we even have differentiation
within it so if you've ever seen the
planet fitness ads about how their gym
is different than the lunk head gyms
right it's still all the same thing you
can show off what you're doing at any of
these these gyms going in and and you
know puttering around and or even being
serious and really applying yourself if
you're doing it here's sort of a rule of
thumb if you're doing it and then you're
looking around to see who's looking at
you or maybe you're looking in the
mirrors because these places all have
lots of mirrors
if you're doing that then you're doing
it for for somebody else or you're doing
it so that you can have something in
relation to somebody else
if you find yourself
you know
engaging in a healthier diet but you
need to make a big thing of it every
time you go to the restaurant you tell
everybody that you've cut out gluten or
that you're vegan or whatever it is that
that you want
then you're following the advice that
epictetus is saying you shouldn't follow
right
you shouldn't try to make a big thing of
yourself you shouldn't try to show off
your choices you might say
we we live in a society that's even more
subject to temptation about this because
we have entire movements right it used
to be if you went for a run for some
sort of activity that was fine now you
get a t-shirt you get to sign up on the
website you get to let everybody know
what a swell person you are for running
for this or that right and you're doing
the run right you're training for the
triathlon you're doing all these sorts
of things epictetus is saying hey if
this is about stoicism and about you
know controlling your body
so that you aren't going to be bothered
by it so that you can focus on what's
really important which is your
personality
then don't do things that are actually
damaging to your personality like
showing off to other people like making
a big thing of it so that they can then
give you praise and you can feel great
also don't do the thing that people do
where they become obsessive about their
body because they want to have some area
in which they have control they do that
because they're so out of control with
respect to their emotions with respect
to their thoughts with respect to what
they could have control over so
epictetus is advice here
of taking the sip of water on a very hot
day and then without anybody else seeing
it spitting it out
we could multiply this into a whole
bunch of other exercises where you're
working on yourself and you're not
worried about what other people are
seeing thinking or even whether you're
developing some sort of essentially
pathological control over your body
this is the position and character of a
lay man he never looks for either help
or harm from himself but only from
externals this is the position and
character of the philosopher he looks
for all his help or harm from himself
signs of one who is making progress are
he censures no one praises no one blames
no one finds fault with no one says
nothing about himself as though he were
somebody or knew something when he is
hampered or prevented he blames himself
and if anyone compliments him he smiles
to himself with the person complimenting
well if anyone censures him he makes no
defense
he goes about like an invalid being
careful not to disturb before it has
grown firm any part which is getting
well
he has put away from himself his every
desire and has transferred his aversion
to those things only of what is under
our control which are contrary to nature
he exercises no pronounced choice in
regard to anything if he gives the
appearance of being foolish or ignorant
he does not care
in a word
he keeps guard against himself as though
he were his own enemy lying in weight
at multiple places in his discussions
epictetus will differentiate between
what we're translating here as the
layperson the idiots in greek the person
who is not versed in philosophy or
practicing philosophy meaning stoic
philosophy
and the person who is
in some way a philosopher in that
they're pursuing a philosophical path
here he talks in terms of the um
the person who is making progress the
pro
um you know the one who is advancing uh
not not necessarily in terms of the
person who's actually made it to the end
and has it all together and he says
here's what a a
person
who is
not making progress looks like the
person who is at the starting point we
might say
he never
looks for help or harm from himself
that's a key thing right there
he never looks for help or harm from
himself but only from externals
so
you know this could extend as well to
those who rely upon their bodies to get
them through things it could be because
of physical attractiveness it could be
because they've built up you know great
great you know physique or something
like that and they think that that's
going to get them through the the
problems or they've been doing a lot of
yoga or you know whatever
other externals that people rely upon
wealth
reputation
other people's opinions and viewpoints
position we could go through all sorts
of examples of the things that epictetus
says are external and outside of our
control and the person who is not
engaged in in stoic thought is is going
to naturally because this is the way
human beings do in fact behave in our
cultures naturally think that that's
where our help really lies that's where
our security lies so they don't look
within
he says this is the position and
character of the philosopher he looks
for all his help or harm from himself so
that's that's the ideal the philosopher
looks within and finds the resources
that he or she needs
as epictetus has told us in other
passages if we do in fact look within we
may not find the full-blown virtue if we
haven't developed it yet of temperance
or justice but we do find the resources
that we need and we realize that we have
choices to make if we allow ourselves to
be overcome by situations that don't
have to overcome us that is our choice
and if we thought that you know waiting
for some sort of external thing like
somebody else to come in and save the
day was the right thing to do well
that's part of why we we failed and we
could have chosen otherwise and if you
look back through through your your life
if you decide that you want to go on
this path you'll see plenty of juncture
points where you could have chosen
otherwise instead
you look for help or harm from from the
externals
now he says the signs of a person who is
making progress are these
he doesn't blame anybody he doesn't
censure is how it's translated here sega
is is the greek term for it he also
praises nobody now does that mean that
you can't ever say to your your
colleague or your child or your friend
oh good job or anything like that
no it doesn't mean that you can't do
that praising in the sense of you know
lauding uh
excessively saying that this person has
really totally got it together they've
they've you know finished the goal of
life or anything like that
he also blames no one he finds fault
with no one says nothing about himself
as though he were somebody or knew
something so two very important things
blaming and finding fault uh again you
know the the person who is not
practicing this is going to blame other
people they lose their temper it's their
that person's fault
they had a bad day it's the world's
fault
you know traffic is is getting to them
why can't all these people get the hell
off the road you know we can go on and
on with examples like this and centering
blaming uh finding fault with
these are things that gradually are
going to get phased out as one practices
stoic philosophy why would they get
phased out because you realize that
those are things that lie within
other person's power or perhaps the
power of natural processes not within
one's own power so they're not things
that can really harm you or help you
and you're going to cease to be quite so
attached and upset about them you're in
technical terms you're not going to let
your desire and your aversion go out
into the world where they're vulnerable
to being disappointed
now the the other part
saying nothing about oneself as though
he were somebody or knew something this
doesn't mean that that one has to be
affected
and you know pretend like one doesn't
know anything when somebody calls on you
in class when you're in the meeting and
you do have a good idea
but you're not going to talk about
yourself as if you're an important
person you'll just talk about yourself
as a person and the world is full of
persons right there's a whole bunch of
them you're concerned more with one than
others because you're that person
but there's no reason why everybody else
should be subjected to your own
narrative your own interpretation of how
you you know fit into the grand scheme
they can figure that out right if it's
based in reality hopefully they can see
that even if they don't that's up to
them it's not up to you
so you know getting into this practice
is saying yes i'm not really
somebody
that that matters except to myself and
perhaps the people who decide that i
matter to them
he goes on and he says when when a
person like this is hampered or
prevented he blames himself now this is
a very important point
so
one of the goals of stoicism is to reach
a point where we're not being hampered
or prevented we're not being restricted
because we're only choosing to do the
things that we actually do have control
over
we're only choosing to
want things to be the way that they they
are
or you know choosing to manage the
little bit of area that we have you know
which is our ourselves
to make things be the way that we want
them to be
so
when we find ourselves being hampered or
hindered
it's in part because we've let other
things come in
and decide for us so here's an example
we all have bodies and the bodies quite
often don't look the way we would like
or act the way that we would like and as
they age there's probably more and more
of this that happens for for most of us
right perhaps some people age very well
but that seems to be in in large respect
um not just a matter of whether you
exercise or diet but also the genetic
lottery
so
if you find yourself in your feelings in
your thoughts about things
being hampered by what your body looks
like or feels like as you age
there's something going on there that's
a problem
from a stoic perspective this would call
for analysis why why am i finding that
my feelings are being hampered by the
way that my body looks
it could be you know a sense of sense of
shame or something like that there may
be all sorts of other external factors
involved you know we we live in a
culture that tends to say youthful
bodies are good old bodies are bad even
though we have the the obligatory you
know especially since the boomers are
now retiring ads that say old bodies are
beautiful too
a lot of people don't really believe
that if you find yourself being upset
about that epictetus says okay then if
you're being a stoic you would realize
that you're being hampered or prevented
in some way and you would blame yourself
you would say there's something wrong
with the way i'm looking at things it's
not just that the world is messed up and
oh i need to go carry a protest sign
about these advertisements uh around
procter and gamble or something like
that or get on message boards i can't
believe that they think that old bodies
don't look good or something like that
instead you can focus on yourself and
say why is it that this is bothering me
why is it that i let this get to me and
if you carry out an analysis like that
then you can start reworking the way in
which you think and feel about the topic
he goes on and he says if somebody
compliments a person like this
he smiles to himself at the person
complimenting why does he smile to
himself at the person complimenting does
he smile because he says oh i'm so glad
they finally figured out what a great
guy i am no he's smiling because he says
well
clearly whatever this person
complimented me on he thinks that's a
good thing and if we put it into a
broader perspective maybe that's not
such a big deal but if they want to be
nice and compliment me that's that's
fine when another person censures them
says oh you're a bad person you're doing
the wrong thing uh he makes no defense
why why does he make no defense
well perhaps because
oftentimes defending ourselves doesn't
really succeed we defend ourselves in
large part
talking past the other person you know
when somebody criticizes us if they have
a criticism that's on base then you know
really we ought to take it into
consideration and say yeah you're right
about that if it's off base it's off
base because they've got a mistaken
viewpoint on things and we defending
ourselves against them and telling them
how they've got it wrong how they're the
one really at fault and etc etc
is probably not going to get through to
them let alone change their mind it may
add fuel to the fire
so if if the goal is to to work out a
good relationship with another person it
can be counterproductive at times to
defend yourself
particularly if you don't have all these
things sort of straight in your own head
then you can end up launching a tax
yourself
so he goes on and here's the the most
interesting piece of advice he says a
person like this goes around like an
invalid being careful not to disturb
before it is grown firm any part which
is getting well so when you're sick like
you know you break an arm right they put
your arm in a cast
you know or or maybe it's in a splint or
who knows what else right
um
you don't keep keep working out with
that and you try not to mess it up you
want it to heal
so similarly
if you know that you have
problems in a given area of your life
and you're working on those you will be
extra careful
not to screw those things up
because when they if we're going to
follow this medical metaphor out
if something heals wrongly it's going to
be misshapen and you're never really
going to be able to use it well
so
if you know if the bones need to be set
if the muscles need to reconfigure
themselves if
you know a wound has to heal
you have to give it the time and not
keep poking at it not keep messing
around with it so
he goes on and he says he's put away
from himself every desire and he's
transferred his aversions to those
things only of what is under our control
which are contrary to nature this was a
point that he made back in chapter two
he said if you want to make progress
what you have to do is don't allow your
desires to drag you out into paying
attention to all the things in the world
like how people think about you or
whether you're getting that promotion or
not it's not that it doesn't matter at
all
but
you don't have to be driven by desire to
focus on it great example of this you
post something in social media
you know people do this all the time
they'll post something and then they go
back to it how many likes did i get how
many likes do i get and then they're sad
if they didn't get enough likes or
they're happy if they did get a bunch of
likes or maybe happy and then sad
because they didn't get even more likes
because they see somebody else's post
but that going back to it over and over
again that's not good for you
that's that's behavior that actually
sets up a bad habit because it's it's
easy to do over and over right you can
set up habits with respect to social
media within a matter of days
which is one reason why it's so so
addicting and problematic
so
we we do want to transfer our aversion
to what is under our control
if we instead of being averse to other
people saying bad things about us we
should be adverse
to our own tendencies to do things that
are bad
bad for us bad for other people
we should be averse
to the
emotional demands that we place upon
ourselves and then experience which lead
us into counterproductive activities and
choices
so we can start digging into ourself and
saying
that part of myself i don't really like
we can be averse to it that can help us
then when we want to change things when
we want when we get to the moment where
we actually have some possibility of
changing of deciding
so he goes on and he says he exercises
no pronounced choice in regard to
anything
that is very strong choices right
you kind of withdraw this is that part
about being an invalid for a while
you've got to kind of let things be the
way they are
so that you can work on on yourself on
strengthening your inner resources on
healing yourself
and then he says
this person if he gives the appearance
of being foolish or ignorant he doesn't
care why not because it doesn't matter
what other people think other people can
think that he's foolish or ignorant or
backwards or not taking advantage of
opportunities placed in front of him or
whatever
that's their business that's what's
within their control that's not within
his control and he finishes by saying in
a word he keeps guard against himself as
though he were his own enemy lying in
wait now this is a very interesting way
of of phrasing things um we are you know
when we say that that person is his own
worst enemy
epictetus is saying that's really the
case for for all of us
um particularly if we haven't been
working on ourselves looking within
ourselves reflecting on the kinds of
choices that we've made and what kind of
person
those choices display and whether we're
happy with that kind of person if we
haven't been doing that we are
we we have an enemy within the gates and
that enemy is our self
so
this isn't to say that you you know
split yourself off into you know good
person bad person in a very manichaean
sort of way but rather we we think of
ourselves as somebody who is is liable
to do the things that we we don't want
to do and if we do that we can in fact
be confident that we we can control
ourselves it's going to take a lot of
work and time and effort but we do have
the capacity for for choice uh the
stoics think that this is this is the
case for every human being
so
this shows you
i think in very practical terms
what progress looks like from
epictetus's perspective what would it be
to actually
move along the stoic path towards the
end goals
of a fully you know developed
and realized human personality a person
who is happy a person who is tranquil
and a person who is untroubled
[Music]
you